c'est vous qui avez choisi toutes les
tenues on va en parler on va voir les
tenues marins ça va c'est vous qui avez
tout choisi absolument absolument après
forcément
valide évidemment c'est tout un travail
en amont mais effectivement de base
c'est moi qui ai choisi et qui est vue
avec les différentes marques en
participer aussi alors on va voir ce
qu'elle dit aussi dans l'interview
Marlène Schiappa et je vous dis elle dit
pourquoi l'accepter de faire ses photos
qu'on va vous dévoiler dans un instant
les photos de marine Chapa j'ai regardé
le doc sur Pamela Anderson sur Netflix
elle expliquait comment pour elle avoir
posé dans Playboy il faut quelque chose
de positif dans sa vie et dans sa
trajectoire elle avait vécu des
violences sexuelles et avait le
sentiment que son corps ne lui
appartenait plus elle dit que c'était un
acte d'émancipation car elle a décidé
elle sans demander son avis à tel homme
de sa famille ou de son entourage voilà
donc elle a fait en voyant et c'est vrai
que me l'avait dit elle me l'avait dit
ça elle m'avait dit j'avais vu ce
qu'elle m'avait dit il y a longtemps
qu'elle faisait la UNE tu vois ça a
marqué voilà elle m'avait dit elle
m'avait donné la même explication elle
évoque également la liberté sexuelle des
femmes c'est une chose très importante
non déplaise aux autres rétrogrades les
femmes doivent pouvoir faire exactement
ce qu'elles veulent son ambition
a-t-elle envie de se retrouver à
l'Élysée dieu m'en garde je ne veux pas
être chef des armées vous imaginez sur
ce qui pèse sur vos épaules donc elle
veut pas être voilà bien entendu et vous
l'avez interrogé aussi sur ces livres
érotiques qu'elle a écrit avant de
devenir ministre j'ai publié de nombreux
livres érotiques sous pseudonyme à la
fois des guides pratiques quand j'étais
jeune j'ai écouté beaucoup d'hoc et
Difool et les libre antenne à la radio
et je trouvais que ça pouvait répondre à
des questions qu'on n'osait pas poser ni
à nos parents ni à nos profs même à des
amis et elle a même pressenti une petite
polémique et dit qu'on ne s'intéresse
jamais au fond de son discours j'ai
passé plusieurs jours à l'ONU à défendre
la condition des femmes dans le monde et
très peu de gens en parlent d'ailleurs
merci Playboy d'en parler en revanche si
je crée un buzz ou une polémique tout le
monde va en parler c'est cette
dissymétrie qui est très perturbante
dans l'action publique donc elle savait
ça allait quand même créer une polémique
et telle une séductrice j'aime
convaincre et qu'on aime convaincre ça
peut passer par la séduction mais pas
forcément c'est assez difficile quand on
est une femme politique de trouver le
bon dosage voilà alors elle évoque
également un truc les plans à trois
pour qu'avoir choisi Playboy pour faire
avancer le droit des femmes alors que ce
magazine est un condensé de tous les
stéréotypes sexistes vous avez vu ce
qu'elle a dit absolument
pas de quoi elle parlait elle n'avait
lui dire après ce qu'elle a dit mais sur
ça sur vous déjà elle dit que oui ben
elle a pas vu que Playboy avait changé
elle a pas vu que c'est devenu un MOOC
intello elle croit que c'est un journal
de fesses comme beaucoup de gens ça
pouvait l'être il y a 10 ans ou 20 ans
en arrière c'est vrai que vous aviez
demandé d'abord à arroser le bateau oui
elle a dit non et elle a dit non
on aurait pu faire un sujet très marrant
oui mais c'est plus fort
en couverture oui j'aime bien Rosine
Bachelot
vous avez raison alors elle dit donc la
ministre dans qui a remplacé Marlène
chappa au ministère de l'Égalité de
vénère tout genre Isa Isabelle dans
Isabelle Rome vraiment très vénère juste
non c'est là je vais me tourner vers
Gotti Gauthier c'est vrai que c'est fou
quand même au sein du gouvernement celle
qui a pris la place de Marlène Schiappa
réagissent comme ça vous vous montrez
les photos dans un instant vous allez me
dire ce que vous en pensez photos par
photo oui c'est le taquet le plus
violent le plus VMA contre Marlène Chapa
et surtout public parce que vous avez
des ministres qui ont réagi en off sans
donner leur nom à la presse là
effectivement c'est c'est une réaction
en on très véhémente contre Marlène
Schiappa alors ça fait suite aussi au
recadrage d'Elisabeth borne puisque
effectivement n'avait pas prévenu la
première ministre normalement ça se
passe comme ça c'est à dire que Matignon
relie les interviews des ministres donc
là il y a pas eu de relecture et donc
Elizabeth borne ça a fuité dans la
presse a appelé Marlène Schiappa pour
lui demander déjà s'il y avait des
photos nues donc on sait qu'il y a pas
de photo de nudité et pour lui dire que
c'était pas le bon moment et selon mes
infos par contre Emmanuel Macron le
président soutient Marlène Schiappa
soutient sa ministre parce que
effectivement lui il a été dans pygadget
au même moment et Marlène Chapat se
défend en disant que moi je trouve qu'il
y a aucun problème avec il y a aucun
problème contrairement en fait elle a
déjà parler sur les droits des femmes
sur les films contrairement à Madame
schiapparaissant
au début
c'est ça son problème je crois qu'elle a
été dégagée de la convention annuelle
des droits des femmes à New York et ils
ont préféré Marlène Schiappa elle donc
je pense qu'elle a un énorme somme en
fait et alors après ce qui circule aussi
qui circulent aussi du côté de
l'exécutif et de la majorité vous savez
qu'il y a un remaniement qui se prépare
selon certains et Marlène Schiappa
prépare aussi la Suisse de sa carrière
donc c'est aussi un bon coût médiatique
pour faire parler d'elle regarder comme
on en parle
la suite d'accord la suite et la suite
de sa carrière qui saura pas forcément
au gouvernement donc Elisabeth borne
elle était contre elle était surtout
vexé de pas avoir été prévenu puisque
comme je vous le dis il y a un modus
opérandit quand on est ministre on fait
relire ces interviews par Matignon et
effectivement bah Playboy oui c'est pas
une mais c'est pas une interview dans le
Figaro quoi et Emmanuel Macron il est
moi c'est comme on dit dans son
entourage c'est que en tout cas il a pas
recadré puisque ça s'est pas fait savoir
on fait même connaître le contraire
c'est qu'il soutiendrait plutôt sa
ministre oui alors oui mais c'est vrai
que le parallèle entre Playboy et
rivarole il est il est osé alors juste
au niveau des tenues comment ça s'est
passé ça se passe dans le sens où moi je
forcément je prépare des sélections sur
moodboard et tout ça et on en voit au
cabinet au responsable de com de la
ministre pour valider parce que
forcément on va pas commencer la série
en surprise totale et donc c'est un
travail en amont et d'ailleurs quand
quand Jean-Christophe m'a proposé le
projet on devait être début janvier mi
janvier c'est pour ça que sur ce qui est
le phénomène de de conjoncture avec le
planning actuel vous doutez bien que sur
un trimestriel c'est quelque chose c'est
un travail en amont préparer bien à
l'avant et que il y a une coïncidence de
date mais que ça n'a strictement rien à
voir avec le climat actuel sociétal
alors il y a eu également beaucoup de
choses drôles on va voir les photos ni
dans un instant et vous allez voir que
ça fait parler dans le monde entier ça a
été partout en Allemagne en Allemagne
ils ont même fait voilà une une ils ont
fait un article regardez en Allemagne
en Angleterre en Italie alors voilà en
Angleterre en Italie tout le monde a
repris en Espagne au Pays-Bas même en
Inde on a parlé de parler de sapin une
ministre qui peut réussir dans Playboy
donc illustre pas avec les photos
là emmerde pas avec ça et donc c'est
vrai que le buzz est réussi ça il a
parlé dans le monde entier bien sûr sur
les réseaux sociaux ça a été un truc de
fou on a vu quand même quelques
rigolotes sur les réseaux sociaux alors
on va regarder voilà celle-là ce bordel
avec Marlène Schiappa pour au final
ressembler à un emballage
a dû rigoler là-dessus je la connais ça
ça a dû la faire rire après Shaba sur
Playboy voici borne dans Louis donc la
première minute
Elisabeth borne dans Playboy c'est quand
même autre chose regardez
après Macron dans quel magasin
Dupont-Moretti dans l'air Taman
et j'ai déjà commencé ma déco de Noël
regardez la roue bignole
[Rires]
sachez qu'il y avait voilà c'est vrai
qu'il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui parlaient de ça avant ça bruissait
avant et quand c'est sorti forcément
tout le monde a repris le bail alors
Jean-Christophe Laurentin ou c'est un
très beau pour vous vous regrettez pas
une instance un instant d'avoir pris
marine Schiappa on savait que ça allait
faire du buzz bah c'est donc à ce point
là on n'imaginait pas et en faire une
petite affaire d'état encore moins c'est
vrai que c'est une affaire d'état c'est
en train de le devenir elle a ainsi de
mon plein gré mais
tout le monde parle de nous en tout cas
avec l'argent
on va voir on va voir des images du
making-of de Marlène Chapa regardez
alors c'est court mais c'est important
toutes ces cours mais intense
mais c'est bon
on va alors voilà on va voir il y a un
truc qui monte aussi actuellement sur
les réseaux je vous le dis c'est que
dans le même numéro il y a une interview
de Marc-Edouard Nabé accusé
d'antisémitisme de nombreuses fois et
c'est vrai que ça aussi qui monte en ce
moment et qui dit voilà dans le même
numéro il y a Marlène Schiappa et ce
monsieur Gilles oui oui c'est toutes les
polémiques autour de qui est Playboy
c'est ça parfois vous donner la parole à
des gens qui sont c'est vrai
impressionnable c'est d'abord
on donne la parole à des gens qui sont
jugés en fréquentable c'est vrai que
super clivant ça je suis d'accord avec
vous on le défend pas spécialement on
lui donne la parole c'est ce qu'on fait
ici aussi un comptable on leur donne
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on approuve
aussi la parole à Jawad le genre des
terroristes
et on approuve pas du tout on donne la
part à tout le monde il y a toujours des
contradicteurs voilà donc déjà je suis
sûr que si tu étais pas dans l'émission
tu dirais qu'on a pas le droit du tout
mais je répondais à votre question qui
est que la polémique monte là-dessus
parce que les gens trouvent que c'est
chaud
en fréquentable c'est c'est pas mon avis
mais c'est réel et on se dit qui est
vraiment Playboy voilà et c'est pour ça
que des gens disent madame Schiappa
peut-être n'auriez-vous pas dû donner
cette interview alors après il y a eu
c'est une interview de douche pas qui
sera donc dispo dès demain dans cette
interview l'évoque ces combats la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
la liberté des femmes en Afghanistan
l'IVG les droits LGBT donc on a les
photos voici la première photo regardez
voilà alors la première photo bon c'est
vous qui avez choisi la tenue c'est un
tafta oui
[Rires]
c'est un organza réellement la photo là
c'est pas très chaud on va pas se mentir
non mais c'est ça tout le truc c'est que
l'objectif c'est quand même que la
ministre soit digne c'était pas de de
faire quelque chose de
complètement hors zone l'objectif
c'était que l'administre soit digne
qu'elle puisse s'exprimer défendre son
sujet son propos et nous de la mettre en
avant et évident que c'était une super
belle occasion de pouvoir travailler
avec elle et c'est un grand plaisir non
parce que réellement je veux dire j'ai
gardé la confidentialité du projet pour
éviter que ça s'est bruite jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire que la plupart des marques
ayant confiance avec mon travail ils
m'ont dit on fait confiance on sait que
c'est voilà un gros projet voilà donc
elle savait même pas elle découvre
d'ailleurs ce soir pour la plupart là on
est on est on verra tout vu qui est qui
a une très belle c'était cette cape et
cette traîne et voilà l'objectif c'est
d'avoir une femme resplendissante
on était voilà la thématique du shoot
vous l'avez vu vous l'avez compris on
partait un peu dans cette idée de la
Liberté guidant le peuple et de et de
cette nouvelle Marianne un petit peu
voilà donc c'est quoi ça on est sur une
robe ougaro qu'elle porte tout
simplement poser sur son corps et voilà
quelque chose de simple de pur et elle
qui a choisi la robe ou c'est un peu la
hanche
pareillement à chaque fois j'ai proposé
on a validé sur croquer en fait j'avais
préparé des croquises
tout est dans le message
sensible et subtil alors on va voir la
troisième photo là c'est quand elle
était en contrôle de maths
[Rires]
donc là c'est là c'est quoi ces gens
elle s'interroge sur le monde parce que
là pour l'instant je vous dis la vérité
on va voir les autres photos vous allez
voir il y en a une qui est un peu plus
voilà mais pour l'instant franchement
c'est pas cool
alors là moi je lui ai proposé de porter
une fraise parce que en parallèle je
fais aussi couvrier et donc là elle
porte une fraise donc vraiment une
collerette alors
donc voilà mes deux jouets parce que la
fraise c'est quand même le symbole de de
l'ancien régime de tout ça et d'avoir la
fesse tricolore c'est aussi venir monter
quelque chose c'est pas une bonne idée
on le fait pas non elle a été justement
très ouverte à jouer le jeu et à ce et à
se mettre dans le sujet voilà alors
regardez on monte les photos de marine
Chapa donc Playboy il en reste encore 3
allez voir vous les découvrez aussi
peut-être avec nous ce soir ça fait
tellement couler d'encre que vraiment
c'est le sujet du jour regardez la
quatrième photo de Marlène Schiappa ah
ouais alors là oui alors là c'est là on
commence on est on commence à y être
non
mais c'est vrai donc c'est là alors là
on est effectivement sur on a une robe
maison close et une cape Jenny malouf
donc il y a il y a un côté couture tout
devait être bleu mais elle est pas comme
on a entendu dans les rumeurs en drapé
dans le drapeau en étant nu elle est
voilà
porte une sous robe en dessous on n'a
pas de transparence réelle et voilà et
le drapeau partout c'est vraiment c'est
cette idée de liberté guidant le peuple
et de ce côté voilà elle est quand même
jouer là-dessus on m'a dit que vous lui
avez proposé ce qu'on appelle un bout de
bord avant donc avec des petits croquis
de décès photos refusé des photos
qu'elle jugeait pas ministre compatible
alors on a alors c'est pas des photos
c'est sur le mood board bon moi j'avais
les croquis qui présentaient grosso modo
l'idée des cinq six visuels qu'on allait
faire l'idée de la couverture et à côté
de ça on avait des planches avec
effectivement des photos lookbook
présentées par différentes marques pour
proposer un stylisme global donc
qu'est-ce qu'elle jugeait pas ministre
compatible quand on quand on
effectivement il y avait trop de pots
trop de peau visible ou quand ça faisait
peut-être trop mode ou trop rock'n roll
par rapport à ce qu'on voulait présenter
comme sujet sinon par exemple il y avait
la photo la Liberté guidant le peuple
qui est fameux tableau de
Delacroix
la peinture est au Louvre moi je vois ça
bravo
tableau que je connais voilà ça a l'air
voilà
on lui a proposé ce tableau là on lui a
proposé
on a prévu peut-être de faire la coupe
ensemble vous n'avez pas me mettre une
couille à l'air
alors j'aimerais qu'on voit alors
regardez l'autre photo voilà de Marlène
Schiappa alors voilà [__] allez elle
est pas mal elle est très belle
alors ça c'est quoi ça c'est une crête
espagnole mais qui présente à Paris qui
s'appelle ruana Martin et c'est je
trouvais ça sympa d'avoir ce une pièce
plus couture de avec du volume et tout
ça qui peut être sympa et puis il a aimé
cette robe tout de suite elle a trouvé
ça très sympa elle a aussi la même façon
vraiment jouer le jeu et puis voilà et
puis le petit clin d'œil avec avec la
cocarde tricolore et puis Cristiano
à mettre le drapeau français partout
quoi donc si elle avait été même un sein
à l'air on lui aurait mis le thème
c'était vraiment bleu blanc rouge et
elle n'était pas saine moi je trouve que
les photos elle est très belle elle est
pas mal c'est un délire quoi Raymond on
va voir la dernière photo dans un
instant tu vois bravo à vous bravo à
Playboy parce que moi pour moi dans ma
tête c'était Playboy pour moi c'était
des les femmes nues depuis tout le temps
et j'ai vu un interview de Louis de
Funès dans Playboy donc je dis à mon
avis ça a changé Playboy le elle a rien
à gagner elle a pris que des coups à
faire ça c'est fait déboîter à la photo
à faire ça pour moi c'était pas sa place
d'y aller c'est mon avis personnel
c'était pas sa place d'y aller quand à
l'interdit les pétitions pour le Tour de
France parce que on veut pas de femme
objet Playboy c'était souvent l'image de
la femme objet donc c'est de poids de
mesure c'est un truc bizarre c'est pas
cohérent mais bravo à vous bravo à vous
parce que j'ai jamais autant entendu
parler de Playboy et ça peut-être amené
un autre public mais elle avait que des
coups à prendre là-bas elle a été
prendre des cours elle a été gratuit
elle est super hein c'est un amour de
femme elle sait que c'est mon ami voilà
je le dis j'en ai jamais caché et quand
elle me l'a dit
à un moment elle m'a dit voilà j'ai fait
la couverture Playboy je me dis si tu as
raison ça va emmerder tous les connards
donc vas-y euh c'est une très bonne
nouvelle euh regardez tiens on va voir
la dernière
au bas la dernière c'est que bah juste
après elle est nue derrière toujours
alors parce que c'est ça donc là
juste pour c'est vrai que ça fait
énormément énormément parlé aujourd'hui
est-ce que Marlène Schiappa je le dis
elle regrette pas un instant non elle
l'a dit sur Twitter d'ailleurs et je lis
elle regrette pas un instant d'avoir
fait la couverture de Playboy dans ce
qui sera intéressant c'est son coup de
téléphone à Isabelle Rome voilà
elle est pas dire je regrette non non
mais est-ce que est-ce que vous savez
aujourd'hui donc pour elle Elisabeth
band est-ce qu'elle l'a appelé la
première ministre oui à lui ça a été
rendu public elle l'a appelé au moment
où on a appris que cette interview
allait paraître puisque comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure elle ne le savais
pas et elle lui a posé la question
est-ce que tu es nul dans les pages de
Playboy donc marine chapelle lui a
répondu que non c'est tout donc elle a
dit je vais être obligé de faire savoir
publiquement que je t'ai recadrer et
donc elle a fait savoir publiquement
effectivement aux différents services
politiques de France qu'elle avait
recadré sa ministre car c'était pas le
bon moment et que c'était pas le support
adéquat donc et on sait que et ce que
n'a pas fait Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
oui donc Emmanuel Macron il était plutôt
pour je sais pas s'il était pour mais je
pense pas mais il était il a pas voulu
leur cadrer en tout cas les abeilles
borne qui parle de bons moments c'est
quand même la reine on n'est pas le bon
moment non plus ouais c'est pas le débat
juste voilà et donc aujourd'hui est-ce
que tu as oublié tout est rentré dans
l'ordre on va tourner la page comme
voilà donc quand le président de la
République parle gadget sa ministre par
la plus boy bon voilà est-ce que ça
dérange quelqu'un enfin visiblement
plusieurs ministres plusieurs ministres
en off et même celle qui a succédé à
Marlène est-ce qu'il y a des ministres
offres qui ont pas parlé mais qui qui
disent c'est dans inadmissible et qui
ont pas osé parler oui il y a même enfin
il y a des gens qu'on pensait que
c'était un poisson d'avril parce que
vous vous souvenez on la prend le à la
fin du premier avril donc même les
rédactions on pensait que c'était un
poisson d'avril dans un premier temps il
y a des ministres aussi qui ont cru que
c'est un poisson d'avril ils ont dit oui
ils ont dû appeler deux trois personnes
pour être sûr de pour se faire confirmer
oui
est-ce que vous attendez énormément de
ventes de Playboy bah on les expert oui
ça va combien Playboy habituellement on
va
environ 30 000 on va dire donc là vous
êtes en papier le double
tirage
c'est une production qui a coûté cher de
faire la séance photo déjà ou pas c'est
un vrai investissement pour vous pas du
tout pas du tout pas plus que d'habitude
non c'est pas utile
disons que il y a l'affichage sur tous
les médias du monde donc remettez les
photos qu'on a vu toutes les photos
est-ce que ça va se vendre quand même
j'espère
l'article de fond l'article un jour
ça peut être un numéro collector aussi
que les gens ont envie de conserver
juste une petite question surtout
d’heure tu demandais au journaliste
est-ce que ça a dérangé les ministres la
question c'est pas que si ça te dérange
les ministres la question c'est
qu'est-ce que ça dérange les Français
parce que parce que les Français ils
mettent pas des gens au pouvoir pour
aller sur gadget pour aller sur Playboy
pour parler de leur personne à eux ils
mettent des gens au pouvoir pour
s'occuper du pays pas pour faire les
beaux jours
et on va vous intéresser par la réforme
des retraites là justement
pouvoir terminer leur fin de mois
c'est surtout les autres les autres
parties et les autres ministres qui qui
veulent faire du buzz et qui veulent
aussi surfer sur ce buzz oui
Jean-Christophe et d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs quand on regarde
effectivement c'est un buzz mondial dans
les autres à l'étranger c'est plutôt
bienveillant les commentaires sont super
bienveillants il y a qu'en France
bizarrement qu'on trouve de quelques
rages
tous les autres ministres et puis